هذا وكانت القياده الامريكيه الوسطى قد
قالت ان الحوثيين اطلقوا صاروخا بلسيا
مضادا للسفن واصابوا سفينه الحاويات انفي
جالت ايجل واوضحت القياده الامريكيه
الوسطى ان السفينه كانت ترفع علم جزر
مارشال وتعود ملكيتها وادارتها لشركه
امريكيه مضيفه انه لم تقع اصابات او اضرار
جسيمه وان السفينه تواصل رحلتها وقالت
القياده الامريكيه الوسطى انها رصدت
صاروخا فالسيا مضادا للسفن اطلق باتجاه
الممرات الملاحيه التجاريه بجنوب البحر
الاحمر لكنه اصطدم بالارض في اليمن وقالت
الشركه المشغله للسفينه المستهدفه ان
السفينه مستقره وتبحر خارج
المنطقه معنا الان من واشنطن مراسل
الجزيره فادي منصور فادي يعني رغم ان
القياده الامريكيه الوسطى اقرت بان ليس
هناك اضرار او خسائر في هذه السفينه الا
انها اكدت وصول واصابه الصاروخ البلسي
للسفينه لكن ماذا في قراءه تبعات عمليه من
هذا
النوع نعم ايمان نحن كنا تحدثنا الى مسؤول
دفاعي امريكي طلب عدم ذكر اسمه قال
للجزيره بان عمليه استهداف السفينه بهذا
الصاروخ البالستي الذي اصابها حصلت اثناء
ابحارها في خليج عدن ورجح هذا المسؤول ان
تكون السفينه اصيبت خلال مغادرتها تلك
المنطقه واضاف انه لم تكن هناك اي قطعه
بحريه امريكيه بالقرب من تلك السفينه او
لم تستجب اي قطعه بحريه امريكيه بما ان
السفينه جيبرالتار ايجل لم توجه اي نداء
استغاثه اكد هذا المسؤول ان عمليه حارس
الازدهار وهي التحالف الذي شكلته الولايات
المتحده مع نحو 20 دوله سوف يواصل عمله في
المنطقه انطلاقا من منطلقاته الدفاعيه
لحمايه الشحن البحري وكنا سالنا ايضا هذا
المسؤول عن تصريحات مسؤولين من انصار الله
الحوثيين بينهم تصريح للجزيره بان السفن
الامريكيه سوف تكون عرضه للاستهداف قال ان
هذه التصريحات المسؤول الدفاعي الامريكي
قال ان هذه التصريحات الصادره من مسؤولينا
لدى انصار الله الحوثيين لن تغير شيئا في
عمل
التحالف حارس الازدهار لكن هناك حدثان
اساسيان وقعا اليوم في ضوء الهجمات التي
شنتها الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا على
مواقع تابعه لانصار الله الحوثيين في
اليمن خلال الايام الماضيه والتي قالت ان
الهدف الاستراتيجي منها في نهايه المطاف
هي وقف الهجمات على الملاحه البحريه في في
منطقه البحر الاحمر اولا تمكن انصار الله
الحوثيين باقرار القياده الوسطى من
استهداف سفينه شحن امريكيه وهذا حادث بالغ
الاهميه من ناحيه ثانيه البيان المهم
للغايه الذي صدر عن اداره الملاحه البحريه
التابعه لوزاره المواصلات الامريكيه والتي
اوصت جميع السفن التجاريه الامريكيه بتجنب
البحار في جنوب البحر الاحمر وباب مضيق
باب المندب والقسم الغربي من خليج عدن
وهذا اقرار عملي بان هجمات الحوثيين انصار
الله
الحوثيين لم تتوقف بانه لا ثقه بان
الاجراءات العسكريه التي اتخذتها الولايات
المتحده ضد مواقعهم سوف تؤدي الى حمايه
السفن وبالتالي هذا تطور مهم ايمان شكرا
جزيلا لك من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره فادي
منصور